-Our next guest can be seen
at the New York Comedy Cellar
March 4th through the 6th.
Making his "Tonight Show" debut,
please welcome the very funny
Eric Neumann, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you.
Thank you so much.
How we feeling, guys?
We good?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh.
Oh, amazing.
I'm so happy to be here.
Actually, my mom's
a very overprotective mom,
so to be honest, I'm happy
to be anywhere she is not.
[ Laughter ]
She's --
She's super overprotective.
She'll like -- She'll text me
when I'm out at night.
She'll be like, "Call me as soon
as you leave the bar.
I'm worried someone's
gonna follow you home."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "Mom, the whole point
of me going out was to get
someone to follow me home."
[ Laughter ]
She'll call me
in the middle of the night
to make sure I got home okay,
but if I don't answer the phone
'cause I'm busy,
she'll call one of
my best friends looking for me.
[ Laughter ]
I'm 34.
That's unacceptable.
[ Laughter ]
So finally, I sat her down.
I'm like,
"Mom, you have to stop calling
my friends at 4:00 a.m.
You're gonna give them
the wrong impression."
[ Light laughter ]
Right?
'Cause my friends are wasted
at 4:00 a.m.
I don't trust them talking to
my mom on the phone at all.
[ Laughter ]
This is how I see the scenario
playing out in my head,
all right?
My mom calls my best friend,
Joe, at 4:00 a.m.
She's like,
"Hey, Joe, is Eric with you?"
Joe is like, "No, I'm all alone.
You want to come over?"
[ Laughter ]
It's my worst nightmare.
Literally, my worst nightmare.
I just found out my mom and I
have the same therapist.
[ Laughter ]
Which is weird.
It's weird.
But it's fine because he's sworn
to confidentiality.
Like, he can't even
legally admit
that he knows who my mom is.
So sometimes, I like to test him
to see how professional he is.
The other day, I was like, "Oh,
my mom's so overbearing, man.
I can't take it.
She's in therapy to get help
but says her therapist
is an unhelpful moron."
[ Laughter ]
"Can't even believe
he has a degree, really."
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "Oh, that's weird,
because I have a patient
whose son is a real schmuck."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like,
"All right, touché, sir.
You won that battle."
I've gotten my heart broken
so many times.
So many times.
I remember I dated this girl
briefly in fifth grade.
[ Laughter ]
And I haven't seen her
since fifth grade.
Last week, I ran into her
on the street, and she goes,
"Hey, Eric, remember when I
broke up with you in 5th grade
Because the nurse pulled you
out of the classroom
for having lice."
[ Laughter ]
I'm, like,
"You mean the most devastating
moment of my entire life?"
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, I vaguely recall that."
I remember I was so devastated,
I came back into the classroom,
and some kid next to me
was like, "Eric,
why do you look so sad?"
I'm like,
"Because Nadia just dumped me,
and now I'm all alone."
And I swear he pointed
at my head, and he's like,
"No, you're not."
[ Laughter and applause ]
My mom really wants me
to settle down, have kids.
You know, my younger brother
has a 2-year-old daughter now,
and everybody's like,
"Oh, now that your brother
has a kid,
your mom's gonna put
less pressure on you
to have kids."
It's not true.
She doesn't put
less pressure on me,
she's just changed her approach.
That's all.
Like, the other day,
I met up with my mom
and my niece,
and my niece was crying.
I was like,
"Mom, why is she crying?"
And she goes,
"I think it's because
she doesn't have a cousin."
[ Laughter ]
She's a genius.
She's brilliant, that woman.
I take my niece
to go get coffee every morning.
I take her to the coffee shop.
That's our routine.
And I love doing it
for two reasons.
One, she's so cute.
And two,
it is so easy to pick up women.
[ Laughter ]
But only if I make it very clear
that she's not my daughter.
So the other day,
we were at the coffee shop.
Some beautiful girl passed by,
looked at my niece,
and I was like,
"Can you say 'uncle'?"
[ Laughter ]
"Can you say 'single uncle'?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Who's your single uncle, huh?
Who's your single uncle
who will definitely be faithful
this time around
because he learned his lesson?"
[ Laughter ]
Even my friends
are starting to worry about me.
Like, the other day,
my friend goes, "Hey, Eric,
you have to meet a girl
before you become rich
because then you'll know
she really loves you."
He goes, "Look at LeBron James."
That was the example he used --
LeBron James.
[ Laughter ]
He goes, "LeBron met his wife
in high school, right?
So you know
she really loves him.
She dated him before
he was LeBron James."
I'm like, "Yeah, but it's not
like there weren't signs."
[ Laughter ]
"Becky, you'll never guess
who just asked me out.
You know that guy, LeBron,
who's 6'9"
and averages
85 points per game?"
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, the one
who was on the cover
of 'Sports Illustrated'
at 14 years old?"
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, I think I'm gonna
roll the dice on him."
[ Laughter ]
"I know it's a long shot.
I'm gonna go for it.
I have no idea what he wants
to do for his career.
I know, for fun, he likes
to hop over school buses.
But for a career, who knows?"
You guys have been amazing.
I'm Eric Neumann.
Thank you so much, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is --
That's Eric Neumann!
Oh, fantastic job.
He'll be at
the New York Comedy Cellar
March 4th through the 6th.